today we're checking out the button the
worst dating show apparently this is bad
it's bad
Ken just went this I hate this video I
hate it more than anything uh but I'm
ready I'm ready to watch it and finally
I'm the only one who hasn't seen this
like every YouTuber has already made a
video on it and here I am guys guys
check this out keep that innocence man
you don't need to you don't have to
watch should we watch something else can
is it that bad oh no you have to you
have to witness it you have to
experience the horrible I don't know how
they find people so bad
yeah the last time we did a video on the
cut it was just infuriating to watch
yeah oh yeah oh yeah well get ready nice
to meet you you too
I'm sorry oh it didn't turn red yet no
I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
welcome to the so yeah
try to out him before he even started
I've seen I've seen uh Clips on other
videos so I knew what the gist is yeah
gosh like shake his hand the whole
time's like oh I'm so sorry pushing the
button when the button lights up red
either player may press it and swap out
their date for a new person get out of
here if two people can last on a date
for 10 minutes they win an all expenses
paid second date this is the button
they can't click the button right away
until it turns right yeah and I guess
that didn't register to some people yeah
yeah pretty well I just need to figure
out who
would do it what's this Vibe though yeah
what's a similar Vibe like same hair
you look like siblings
they look related yeah
oh you're waiting for me
like she's already yeah yeah yeah yeah
she's she's already leaning forward you
know she was going for it
you found this attractive oh
well usually people date people that
look like and it's kind of weird
surprise didn't work out hey
surprised by that I saw that a mile away
come on
you ain't you ain't clicking this point
okay that's not happening
all right yeah I don't really like guys
with long hair
I'm Nicole Nicole nice to meet you nice
handsome ginger beard you're in the arm
I was in the Army yeah from 2012 to
2016.
oh no worries why did you pass me
I don't know man something about army
guys
16. eight years ago anymore what do you
mean oh oh you were in the Army no I was
in the Army eight years ago
I am so thankful that I am I've been
married happily married for so long
because I would not survive this is what
the modern Daily World is like I feel
bad for everyone out there I'm so sorry
I think uh me and Marshall are watching
uh Married at First Sight yeah and it's
just like people that get married
without ever seeing each other and it's
just like it seems like people get to
this I mean it's not everyone but people
get to this age or he's like [ __ ] I'll
do anything all right I'm tired of this
[ __ ]
please let me find somebody yeah exactly
like damn here's like oh you were in the
Army at one time swipe left or whatever
oh you have long hair don't even get to
know you don't you're like
this is funny because it comes out
because otherwise they will get swiped
and that's the only reason oh boy
I don't I don't I don't they're just
very like
I don't know overly masked
mask seemed like so overly masculine
right look at the sky is this it looks
like a normal dude like what do you mean
brown colors in his his beard that
doesn't match his hair
it's like his hair mixed with his shirt
and then that became
hi I'm Nicole Nicole Omari
cool what are you what are you what are
you fun what do I do for fun video games
mostly video games um
video games yes
[Laughter]
she's snuck in with that
um video games huh yeah yeah you play
video games
[Music]
because there's more to life than video
games you asked him what he does for fun
not what his entire life is based around
this one's video is one of the most
awful videos ever made is because
that's so what do you do for fun oh
anything
purpose what a life than that
my God
you nerd
hi is it your mission to get me out is
everyone like Angry well I don't know I
don't know about that I've heard about
you though
let's get her out of here she picked up
on that Vibe that's [ __ ] funny does
everybody hate me
all the boys were like hunkered into it
in a circle like oh yeah
there's also a thing
you've never watched before is that they
usually end up cycling back to the same
guys again because the girls bust
through them so fast oh no way so we'll
see some we'll see some old Faces by the
end of this oh no old vpns nordvpn
nordvpn greatest VPN nordvpn has
launched a cyber security awareness
campaign a camera bite they love you
help protect yourself from man in the
middle attack fishing
malware and more you connect to a public
Wi-Fi in your local coffee shop but
anyone can make these networks easy and
still all the information that you put
in bada bing bada boom you're broke now
they stole the whole bang suddenly
paying nordvpn subscription fee not so
bad huh you should always use a VPN when
you connect to a public Wi-Fi dummy
oh you have no VPN okay you're good
protect yourself from phishing attacks I
did this when I was 14 to my friends to
sell their MMO gold
I'm sorry it's fake websites and links
that can appear in your email or
anywhere really that looks just like the
real website but it's a decoy to steal
all your information when you log in
nordvpn coming in clutch again with
their threat Protection Service just one
click on the button
they keep you safe from this as well but
not just malicious websites did I
mention downloads trackers and intrusive
ads threat protection is looking out for
you even when you're not using a VPN and
of course all your internet data stays
safe when you're connected to a VPN no
one seeks your history bro no logs
next-gen encryption and of course you
can watch shows anywhere here in Japan
it's been a goddamn Lifesaver Bing Bang
Boom I'm back in UK and I'm watching
fleabag
and no more awkwardly dubbed movies on
television thank you nordvpn
it's right if
someone's for free as well use the link
in description thank you no VPN for
sponsoring this video boom I'm good how
are you uh I'm you know I'm doing all
right it's I'm not really a morning
person by this time I usually have had
like two red bulls or something like
that oh okay
um
decided at that moment
if anyone answers what you just said
with oh okay you know
they've judged you forever I wish I knew
what their names were but they never
introduced themselves just sit down and
just start pushing buttons oh this is a
race to the button what do you do uh I I
tried to get a yeah yeah there you go
why did you impress me
he's not my type next day please
I mean two red bulls in the morning
that's yeah bruh Yeah Boy come on you're
always gonna watch out for the ones that
are asking the questions too because
I'll ask the question so the person's
thinking about it and then you'll turn
and they're like you didn't finish but
I'm pushing the button anyway
really rude man yeah God yeah I'm
getting the tutorial and then walk
through with you here this is great I
wonder what the call sheets are for for
the cut you know because they find the
worst people all the time uh we're
looking for people who were just
completely unbearable uh
well the people that are are this
unbearable are like uh mean or whatever
they don't know that they are they think
they're good people ah so they should be
like we're looking for the best people
ever and then we're looking for the best
that's totally me yeah yeah I'm the best
oh interesting did not expect that I
didn't get the memo about are we
dressing up or yeah what's going on yeah
so I am what do you call a furry and I
just dress up and I put smiles in
people's faces so do you have like this
I only have one
she had it too fast look at her cringing
let's panic in that woman's face
[Music]
don't make me lose
your chance listen I don't I'm not I
don't I don't know about furry but at
least you could try you know this is
your chance to try and get to know the
person right yeah I mean she looks like
she needs a hobby of some kind you know
something to like you know
the video games yeah yeah which no she
probably she's probably playing League
of Legends she looks like she's pretty
sweet and angry
I did it first careful careful
until you're rejected okay sorry I'm
sorry no no no don't follow that you're
good
oh my God yeah dude does he does he seem
lovely I know you're pretty aggressive
if he's so lovely and why were you so
quick on that button huh you wouldn't
have to be so sorry if you guys would
stop pushing the button you know oh I'm
so sorry oh my bad you know what has
anything lasted more than 10 seconds
like a question no I'm Patrick oh Patty
yeah oh we know her name now wow an
introduction a virgin
no I'm not
what what nice to meet you oh Patrick
and Penny yeah Patty are you a virgin
Oh I thought he asked her none that's
why his face was so shocked I was like
what
did I just say
are you a virgin yes I am oh okay do you
usually have to tell people the fun out
of them okay
[Music]
reject her is it because she's not a
virgin no it's because she's older than
me honey
ah I can tell yeah you guys look like
you're the same age actually I love how
she thanked him like like she was like
so spiteful that he hit the button first
she's like thank you you suck you know
virgin
so how's your day going today my day is
good I'm scared but um why are you
scared ah first time doing this can you
tell me more about yourself uh I'm a
student
interesting accent I like it
what what she was ready yeah yeah how
are you so ready before that question
you didn't even care about the answering
uh I'm a student
did I'm telling you 23. she was so ready
alligator holy [ __ ] and it's the people
who ask the questions to always hit the
button they're like oh yeah yeah because
yeah
in the qualify for like oh that's not
good enough all right gamer yeah yeah
yep 23 yeah yeah that's the reason
what's your dating age range above 25
and then stopping at like 36.
I want to see this that's a nice smile
you do too are you from L.A oh okay they
might hit it out okay I was born there
moved out here when I was like one so
you're from here kind of no I understand
yeah okay
how do you feel it
I'm not sure I feel good okay so one
thing that's big for me is music music
yeah so okay they haven't hit the button
more like hip-hop
no I just was having fun I cannot dance
at all everybody can dance no everybody
I am dancing together yeah
why
what was the problem
oh that's great button
I got it here
I appreciate you you were fun though we
could be friends all right
I know we can't but why there's a reason
why this video has three million views
nobody gets it
all right
yet no I'm so sorry oh God
click it click it I'm Gabrielle
give each other a chance yeah let's give
each other a chance let's let's Okay I
do see you as a friend though no yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
let's give each other a chance he had
already decided look you can see it in
the subtleties oh yeah of course he was
pushing the button even sat down of
course it was over with Jesus he's outed
five people and she doesn't know the
rules that it has to turn red are you
kidding me she just like sees him no God
no button please oh he keeps pressing
and hoping somebody will change I'm so
sorry give each other a chance yeah
let's give each other a chance let's
look okay look look he puts his hands
back on the table he was like hey let's
give each other a chance but I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna
hi I'm Joel nice to meet you you too all
right maybe this will be civilized good
I'm a little nervous yeah yeah like my
hands were like freezing earlier just
like yeah so I like ice cold because
they're just nervous but
um
okay
[Music]
sorry
why you don't rejected Joel
nobody knows children this is kids this
is probably just fun to press the button
I'm just convinced that but I'm just
like get to know someone no no I'm just
yeah just like big red button gotta
click it bro sorry like the whole point
of this thing is from the last 10
minutes and then they get like money or
they get to go like all paid date or
something so they could just like go
hang out they don't actually have to
date
but no might as well push buttons why
did you ask me it was a little bit like
forced
what were you making it takes two people
to tango okay yeah
this guy's back they made the show there
he is
I just hate how like it's just based off
like looks that's literally all it is
they sit down they look at him and go me
and that's it it doesn't matter what
they say yeah
how much money do you make but I'm a
billionaire maybe she's like oh wait
maybe maybe I shouldn't push the button
no no it's just uh I don't like the way
you look man yeah we we're the lucky
ones who got out before Tinder every
joke for a video
oh you made Tinder profiles we did one
time for like the little podcast we both
made one and we I don't think yeah
because they wouldn't I don't remember
something really I have no memory
whatsoever yup yup yup all right all
right he's back I'm doing pretty good I
got pressed so fast last time oh you've
you've been here before like you've done
it we went through the whole thing
already
why do you think you got an extra boy
um well I don't think we found each
other attractive oh okay I said it and
she and she I thought you were about to
do it so I thought you're about I was I
was like I I won't do it quickly if you
don't do it okay can we make a truce
sure but that means they both decided to
do it yeah they're just trying to be
more civil about the button pricing
projection sucks who would like it right
and I think like most people are pretty
egocentric so like rejection is I think
everyone in this video I think we think
that it reflects something about us as a
person always sometimes now it's like I
knew it they had both we're gonna reject
about this she said I will not do it
quick
she said that
you lying son of a [ __ ] they're both
getting rejected thank God get them both
out of here that's a tie
[Laughter]
can't [ __ ] do they think it's like yeah
if I press the button then they can't
reject me
yeah I think so that's literally all
it's about yeah it's just a game imagine
like wanting to try so hard in this
let's not hitting the buttons not even
how you win the game
the 10 minutes is how you win the game
not pushing the button is the point of
the game I mean I wouldn't want to go on
a date with these people yeah you're
right like get me out of here dude
listen you take the whatever free thing
is go with your friend all right and we
can all get out of here
hi I'm Jordan nice to meet you how tall
are you oh I'm 5 11 and a half she does
look quite tall okay I don't believe
that me and my sister go and get a lot
of coffee try different coffees around
the city try different beer um depends
on what time of day I guess do you drink
too much my mother might say I drink too
much but I feel like others think I
drink just enough breakfast booze taste
like
blues or boobs please clarify both do
you swing both ways no all right so
boobs taste like I feel like it tastes
like any other part of your body since
it's all you know I guess that's true
that's your favorite part of a body to
taste
Jesus
um I'm a lip girl so I mean I live a
kiss they just like extended the button
now so they have to talk and it's awful
actually I wish they would press the
button now
I can't imagine sitting down in like a
little dating show and somebody like so
what do you do for fun and I answer them
I drink coffee
I drink coffee
there's more to life
how often you see like the Spaceman
like every day
damn she hit that hard Jordan
why did you reject him
I didn't feel the spark
I mean that one I get that was awkward I
wouldn't want to sit there for 10
minutes keep doing whatever that was
talking about coffee and sucking on
boobs
I'm Kat nice to meet you yeah nice to
meet you okay I feel like these two
could hit it up how's your morning you
feel like they too was that what do you
why do you feel like they can hit it off
because they like they look like in the
same region of dating if they said they
were dating I would believe it okay
how's your morning I didn't know I was
coming here so I didn't know about that
until like eight what does that mean I
mean I was a last minute Switcheroo oh
you were forced to be here no not
against my will
some epic flirting like
all right you are single yes I am single
they did not bring a ticket person here
what do you do for work
um I'm a software engineer oh wow what
do you do I do construction or like a
carpentry I lay wood and decks you build
stuff that's way too many click the
button something to fall over so well
kudos I can teach you
mine's kind of cute you're very
attractive oh are they gonna pair yeah
you're very very attractive oh they are
gonna pairs
but turns you guys on what turns you on
yes
um depends on the situation it's like oh
he can fix something like that's cool or
oh
I can fix things how convenient what
turns me on yeah what you do I mean you
already knew this was going to go well
because they like actually asked each
other questions what did you do for work
shocker that hasn't been asked yet I
don't think yeah you're right so they
are gonna work out no um I'm like almost
six foot okay I'm six he's growing so I
can definitely reach higher than you
yeah that's good because otherwise she
would have clicked the button
baking
I read a lot and that's like my hobby I
read a lot of stuff that my pastor tells
me to read oh
oh that could be a clicker for some
people
he's religious that question are you
religious I meet with my pastor pretty I
like once a month just yeah you're
religious so say yes another male role
model in your life because I don't I
don't have a dad right now or dad oh
okay now I feel bad
was that deal breaker for you it's not a
deal breaker I'm just very not religious
sorry Mom is that a deal breaker for you
Ryan Ryan my mom's not religious either
interesting all right
um You my sisters like try out different
breweries around town oh really yeah
there's one opening up today oh what is
it because now I might have plans this
afternoon yeah yeah right maybe
Ryan ask her out how hard is it
push the button
push the button would you want to go out
again sure I'll go out with you again
oh no it's gentle absolutely not leave
me alone
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God finally someone I didn't think
they would oh yeah you did as soon as
they sat down you're like okay this is
I'm you can just look at it and tell
that they could it was gonna happen it's
weird how I knew that right she didn't
like guys with long hair and disliked
man being too masculine yeah she was
[ __ ] God that was great I love that that
was nothing wrong with that that was
perfect
what do you do for fun Felix uh play
video games
I feel like they had to reply based on
what happened but in reality they just
probably didn't find them attractive
yeah yeah they're just fine right yeah
yeah it was whatever if you enjoyed this
video like subscribe I have other videos
with the cup with the can check them out
and uh
see ya